but uh but we've been doing that i've
been playing a lot of playstation and
watching a lot of films and catching up
on film history
and uh and and like i said drinking a
lot i actually said this weekend that
i was gonna stop drinking for a week i
was gonna have a week off
and then literally monday morning i've
got my own prop
ryan reynolds sent me a case of gin
oh really so as i literally literally
was like this morning i'm not drinking
the whole week i'm not drinking at all
and then literally the doorbell rang and
there was there was
a case of gin from lovely ryan so i
think that's
deadpool trying to corrupt spider-man is
what's going on here
it says here on the box it says some
friendly neighborhood spider gin
love ryan if i'm wrong correct me but i
believe you were supposed to start
shooting spider-man in july is that
still the plan
uh i'm not too sure i'm not too sure i
was i was in berlin
making a film called uncharted with mark
wahlberg and uh we were all ready to go
we went to set for day one shooting and
then we got shut down and we all got
sent
home so whether we shoot that movie
first or we shoot spider-man first i'm
unclear but uh but i don't know but both
movies are being made and they're both
really strong and the scripts are
fantastic so whatever happens happens
but
i'm ready to play both i mean i've
played spider-man enough now i could
play him tomorrow so
it's ready to go i'm speaking with thor
tomorrow
and i was wondering if you've been video
chatting with your fellow avengers
uh i spoke to to uh
jake gyllenhaal the other day we were
talking about doing a peloton class
together we've been trying to get on the
same bike and train together
so i look like a complete idiot um and
then i've been i actually facetimed
downey a couple days ago and he was in
the bath
ah interesting huh how romantic gotcha
but we've also been doing these pub
quizzes these massive pub quizzes
where we've done one with the cherry
crews so the russo brothers have been
involved welcome back everyone is
charlie this is going to be my new tom
holland spider-man 3 video also explain
what's going on with the other marvel
movies during 2021
and the uncharted movie that tom holland
is making right now too
that's right if you ever believe that
they were gonna do an uncharted movie
they're finally making it right now
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a new amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know what kind of
big
spider-man movie crossover you want to
see during marvel phase 4.
so we'll just number these as we go
along starting with number five tom
holland went on jimmy kimmel a little
while ago to promote spider-man 3 in a
couple of his other movies
and talk about how ryan reynolds won't
stop trolling him in real life
he made another movie with the russo
brothers after avengers end game called
cherry that's going to be coming out
later this year that you'll be able to
see
and he even made a movie with batman
himself robert pattinson called devil
all the time that's why if you zoom in
enhance in the background here
it's got that devil all the time banner
hanging behind him on his bookshelf
he's not trying to joke around or
anything like that that's not a mephisto
easter egg even though there's a lot of
mephisto
rumors about stuff during doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness
and this is his house that he lives in
most of the time pretty much all the
interviews that you see on talk shows
right now are people zooming or skyping
from their houses just because
it's so hard to go into a studio i think
some of the talk shows just started
filming
back in their studios though so that'll
change in the next month or two
the good news is that hollywood has
started filming stuff again especially
overseas so that's why you're hearing
about all these movies getting started
again right now
the other big movie that he's talking
about during this is obviously the
uncharted movie
that sony is making a lot of you seem
like you're finding out about it for the
first time too like you didn't know that
sony was making uncharted with
spider-man himself
and mark wahlberg tom holland is playing
nathan drake obviously he just posted
this picture from the set as they're
getting started
mark wahlberg originally tried to get
the movie made years ago but
for whatever reason it just didn't
happen he got too old to play nathan
drake so that's why tom holland is
playing nathan drake
and mark wahlberg is now playing the
sully character that movie is also
supposed to come out during 2021 so if
you're a big uncharted fan
that's also happening right now number
four though you also probably recognize
spider-man's suit that he's wearing
during this surprising jimmy kimmel's
son for his birthday he's actually
wearing a version of the homemade suit
that he keeps at his house from
spider-man homecoming like all
actors try to steal stuff from the set
or big props or stuff that they really
loved while they were making movies
he's even wearing a cloth mask over his
face the only thing that's missing here
is the special goggles that he created
before iron man gave him the stark tech
suit with the
auto irising ability let's see who's on
the screen
does that guy look familiar to you
hey what's up billy is that spidey let
me take this off so i can see you better
hold on let's see that is peter burger
probably the funniest part of this
though three is when he talks about how
ryan reynolds deadpool has been trolling
him in real life
while he's been trying to get dry
sending him a case of aviation gin
for free with the message some friendly
neighborhood spider-gen
just making all the deadpool spider-man
jokes that he possibly can
ryan reynolds himself has actually been
very active during the big quarantine
period he's been doing a bunch of
charity stuff in addition to posting a
bunch of deadpool stuff but if you do
follow him on social
he has been posting a ton a ton of
deadpool stuff recently
he's mostly focused on trolling hugh
jackman with wolverine deadpool stuff in
the x-men universe and then tom
holland's spider-man stuff
that fell apart quickly this is just you
and me logan
i guess so you know uh you know what
that
makes this a reunion for x-men origins
reunite
yeah but ryan reynolds was watching this
interview while it was happening
watching tom hall and talk about trying
to get dry trying not to drink for a
week and then all of a sudden ryan
reynolds sends me this giant case of
booze
you can see all of his posts here like
oh no how could i have known although if
you ever do sort of gin brand you could
call it alcohol and
aviation gin is a real brand though that
brian reynolds bought two years ago so
if you wonder why he keeps posting all
these parody commercials and clips
for this gin brand that's why he even
did a big one with hugh jackman that's
pretty funny
just them trolling each other with
deadpool wolverine stuff like they have
some sort of real life behind the scenes
feud although this is meant to be a
parody
i know everyone wants to see some
deadpool spiderman crossover deadpool
wolverine crossover in the mcu
but they could always give him a small
cameo in somebody else's movie in some
funny post-credits scene that doesn't
necessarily have anything to do with the
actual plot of the movie
but number two important stuff when tom
holland is talking about filming
spider-man 3 in the uncharted movie
originally he was supposed to be filming
spider-man 3 right now before the big
virus shutdown and everybody had to go
into quarantine
even though it sucks it is kind of funny
that they literally had to cancel
filming the uncharted movie earlier this
year on the second day of work
because of the virus he didn't even make
it two days on that movie
what sony wound up doing to reschedule
both of these movies though is they
decided to film spider-man 3
and the uncharted movie back to back
without giving tom holland any breaks in
between
kind of the same way they filmed
avengers infinity war in avengers end
game
the only difference with the way that
they filmed those two marvel movies is
technically they did it at the same time
like the avengers actors said that they
weren't sure some days if the scenes
they were filming were for
infinity war or if they were for
avengers endgame so right now
literally as i'm posting this video tom
holland is starting to film the
uncharted movie
that will last till at least around
september for him then they're supposed
to start filming spider-man 3
around september no hard dates on that
yet because
it just depends on how things go while
they're filming uncharted but they will
be doing spider-man 3 for the rest of
the year after that and probably a
little bit during the early part of next
year
so if you remember all the cool
behind-the-scenes clips and all the
previews that we got while they were
filming spider-man far from home
all do videos like that when they are
filming spider-man 3 it'll be the exact
same situation for the most part
spider-man 3 isn't coming out till
november 2021
so for those of you that are wondering
when the spider-man 3 trailer is going
to release that's probably going to be
sometime around march with the morbius
movie maybe just a little bit after that
in probably a brand new venom 2 trailer
around that time too
but number one here's the crazy thing
with the whole venom 2 in morbius of it
all because we have all those spider-man
easter eggs
now the morbius movie is coming out in
march venom 2 coming out in june
spider-man 3 coming out in november
so there is sort of this crossover
spider-man sinister six
stuff that's going on through the movies
you also have the spider-man vs venom
tom holland crossover stuff that they're
trying to set up
i've already done a couple videos about
what's going on with these morbius
spider-man easter eggs and why it seems
like they're teasing toby maguire
spider-man instead of tom holland
most of that is just a smoke screen
eventually it'll all make sense and
it'll be more about tom holland's
spider-man and easter eggs for that
then you have all the pictures that tom
hardy has been posting of
venom versus spider-man he's just trying
to get people hyped up
for venom versus spider-man eventually
in the movies
the other big 2021 marvel movies that
are coming up are marvel eternals
the loki avengers end game spin-off
shanxi in the legend of the 10 rings
which is kind of like marvel's remake of
bruce lee's enter the dragon only with
an actual dragon spider-man 3 of course
the morbius movie venom 2
marvel's what if series and then the
hawkeye series which is supposed to be
at the end of next year
there's a bunch of really big stuff
coming next year
things will get better in terms of
really cool content coming from the
studios so of course i'll do easter egg
videos for everything but leave all your
requests in the comments below
and let me know what kind of big venom
spiderman and deadpool crossovers do you
want to see
in the upcoming movies will you wait for
everything click here for my brand new
deadpool 3
ryan reynolds video and click here for
my brand new lucifer season 5
netflix trailer thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe i'll see you
guys tonight
you